>> Sean: SPEAKER PELOSI IS
BERATING THE MEDIA MOB FOR NOT
DOING ENOUGH TO HELP SELL THE
DEMOCRATS EXTREME GREEN NEW DEAL
AGENDA.
YOU CAN'T MAKE THIS UP.
TAKE A LOOK.
>> YOU NEED TO DO A BETTER JOB
IN MESSAGING.
HOW DO YOU SELL THIS?
>> YOU ALL COULD DO A BETTER JOB
OF SELLING THIS TO BE FRANK.
EVERY TIME I COME HERE, THE
ISSUES ARE IN THERE.
IT IS TRUE.
IT IS HARD TO BREAK THROUGH WHEN
YOU HAVE SUCH A COMPREHENSIVE
PACKAGE.
>> Sean: I THINK YOU COULD DO
A BETTER JOB SELLING IT.
THE MEDIA.
HERE WITH REACTION WHO SHOULD
HAVE HIS OWN SHOW.
JOE CHONCA.
YOU SHOULD DO A BETTER JOB
SELLING OUR NEW GREEN NEW DEAL
OF SOCIALISM.
>> THAT WINS LINE OF THE WEEK
AND WE ARE NOT HALFWAY THROUGH.
I HALF EXPECTED HER TO LECTURE
THAT COFFEE IS FOR CLOSERS AND
ABC ALWAYS IS CLOSING.
IT'S HOW THE DEMOCRATS EXPECT
THE MEDIA TO SELL WHAT THE
LAWMAKERS SHOULD BE SELL.
THIS IS LIKE SELLING ADVANCED
SELLOFF TICKETS FOR THE JET.
IT CAN'T BE DONE.
PELOSI AND THE PRESS SECRETARIED
THIS OVER AND OVER AGAIN.
TRILLION DOLLARS WILL COST THE
AMERICAN TAXPAYER ZERO DOLLARS
AND REDUCE TAXES AND THE DEBT.
THAT'S AN INSULT TO ANYBODY'S
INTELLIGENCE.
PELOSI EXPECTS THE PRESS TO SELL
THAT?
.
>> Sean: JEN PSAKI SAID THE
PRESIDENT FEELS LIKE COMING OUT
OF THE PANDEMIC IS THE TIME TO
DO THIS.
WE CAN'T AFFORD THE TRILLION
DOLLARS.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE.
NOR WILL ANY OF THEIR PROMISES
BE FULFILLED.
>> I WOULD LIKE ONE REPORT TO
SAY HOW DO WE REBUILD THE
ECONOMY WHEN INFLATION IS AT A
30 YEAR HIGH?
I AM PRETTY SURE THAT WILL CAUSE
MORE INFLATION.
AND A MYRIAD OF OTHER PROBLEMS.
THEY ARE KNOW GETTING THAT
QUESTION.
>> Sean: THAT'S WHY YOU DESERVE
YOUR OWN SHOW.
YOU ARE NOT PART OF THE TWITTER
AND MEDIA CULT.
>> I WANTED THE BACHELOR.
THEY GAVE IT T